[Musica]
buongiorno a tutti sì grazie
dell'introduzione in effetti oggi darò i
numeri
esatto farò i numeri in senso letterale
e il senso figurato senso letterale
perché sono un economista
l'economista è l'uomo dei numeri uno cui
piacciono dati percentuali probabilità
eccetera
senza figurato perché sono anche un
ambientalista e come ambientalista sono
un po stufo delle promesse non mantenute
da rai numeri anche perché sono un
economista ambientale messo insieme
quindi per definizione un folle un folle
sì perché cerca di conciliare la
crescita economica con la difesa del
pianeta la difesa dei posti di lavoro
con quella della biodiversità insomma io
credo di essere come tutti gli
economisti ambientali una sorta di
equilibrista che cammina su un filo
molto sottile sospeso tra l'economia e
l'ambiente
allora diamo listino ve li
diamo i numeri della crisi anzi delle
crisi perché siamo finiti quella che
sembra una tempesta perfetta crisi
sanitaria crisi economica crisi
ambientale la crisi sanitaria purtroppo
la conosciamo tutti com 19 ha già
generato oltre 5 milioni di morti 5.2
stando alle ultime stime
dell'organizzazione mondiale della
sanità ma anche generato una forte
riduzione del prodotto interno lordo sia
in italia dell 8,9 per cento nel 2020
sia a livello europeo 64 che a livello
globale 3 e 3 ma prima ancora di queste
due crisi ce n'era un'altra la crisi
ambientale
che sempre stando alle stime
dell'organizzazione mondiale della
sanità provocherà 250 mila morti
all'anno nel periodo 2030 2050
ora se qui noi facciamo il conto della
serva ad esempio per 20 finiamo di nuovo
con 5 milioni 5 milioni di vittime
climatici sono una pandemia sono
pandemia silenziosa
invisibile lenta
direi a rallentatore ma gli effetti
drammatici sono gli stessi
che cosa facciamo qual è la risposta
europea e globale a questa pandemia
ambientale chiamiamola così partiamo
dall europa e diamo i numeri dell'europa
l'europa ha cominciato già nel decennio
precedente a programmare una forma di
intervento con un
pacchetto chiamato 20 20 20 ridurre le
emissioni di gas serra del 20 per cento
aumentare l'efficienza energetica del 20
per cento portare le rinnovabili al 20
per cento del totale tutto questo entro
il 2020 rispetto al 1990
è una comunicazione di una strategia di
comunicazione molto efficace ti ricordi
un numero 20 e ti ricordi tutto
negli anni l'europa è riuscita a
raggiungere questi obiettivi anzi la
riduzione delle emissioni si è raggiunta
prima del 2020 e al 2020
siamo arrivati al 31 per cento di
riduzione delle emissioni
per la verità anche grazie a una bella
crisi finanziaria quella del 2007 2008
con strascichi negli anni successivi che
ha rallentato la produzione e dunque
l'inquinamento ma forte di questo
risultato
l'europa ha cercato di alzare
l'asticella è un po come un giocatore di
carte ha raddoppiato la puntata
mirando a ridurre le emissioni del 40
per cento non del 20 al 2030 di fronte
alla pressione dell'opinione pubblica i
movimenti files portiere ma anche direi
soprattutto di fronte alle catastrofi
che il cambiamento climatico prova
oramai anche da noi la commissione
fonder line ha deciso di alzare
ulteriormente quell'asticella a portarla
al 55 per cento entro il 2030 ma come
parte di un progetto un progetto di
lungo periodo che ci deve portare alla
cosiddetta neutralità climatica cioè
emissioni nette pari a zero entro la
metà del set come facciamo
beh
la commissione europea ha proposto un
pacchetto chiamato feat forse ti fai si
pronuncia un po male ma che significa
adatto a raggiungere quell'obiettivo
quel 55 per cento e la pubblicato in una
data non casuale direi il 14 di luglio
presa della bastiglia per dire è una
rivoluzione
e in effetti
è rivoluzionario così come tutto lo
european green deal e rivoluzionario a
mio avviso ha un po una rivoluzione
copernicana perché per la prima volta
mette l'ambiente al centro dell'economia
e non viceversa
speriamo di non dover abiurare ma questa
un po la mia percezione
ora un pilastro del loro piante o più in
generale delle politiche climatiche
europea è rappresentato dal cosiddetto
carbon market cioè mercato per
l'emissione di co2
ve lo spiego in parole povere le imprese
che per produrre inquinano devono
acquistare dei permessi di inquinamento
che devono pagarli se non vogliono
pagarli devono spostare cambiare le loro
tecnologie e utilizzare delle tecnologie
pulite
il che ha un duplice vantaggio da una
parte non devono più comprare permessi
quindi si riducono i costi dall'altra
possono vendere questi permessi alle
imprese che ne hanno ancora bisogno
quindi aumentano i ricavi questo
strumento dovrebbe indurre le imprese a
modificare la propria tecnologia e
dovrebbe portare innovazione tecnologica
ma quanto costa un permesso la risposta
verrà da questo grafico che riporta
l'andamento nel tempo del prezzo dei
permessi e quindi del prezzo per poi che
pago per inquinare in europa
come vedete all'inizio abbiamo avuto una
riduzione del prezzo il grafico parte
dal 2008 è infatti lì c'è la crisi
finanziaria si riduce la produzione si
riduce il bisogno di inquinare e quindi
anche la domanda il prezzo cave e scende
rimanendo basso a lungo sotto 5 euro a
tonnellata fino alla fine del 2017
quando la commissione europea decide di
riformare il sistema e introduce un
meccanismo di aggiustamento automatico
dell'offerta alla domanda e far risalire
il prezzo e lo fare sempre parecchio
nemmeno la pandemia ha affermato questa
ripresa il grazie con sistema se ben
ricordo a ottobre e siamo sopra il 60
euro attore dell'anno
ieri eravamo a 80 euro quindi è un
mercato in rapida espansione e devo dire
anche in linea con alcune previsioni
però fatto gli scienziati o gli
economisti sul prezzo che avrebbe dovuto
raggiungere parlavano e 100 euro a
tonnellata
non è la panacea di tutti i mali
però è uno strumento che può essere
utile soprattutto in quei paesi come
nostri dove esiste già un mercato
sviluppato magari meno nei paesi in via
di fini fatto sta che il modello europeo
è stato preso a modello soprattutto
anche in altre parti del mondo e ad oggi
abbiamo
21 giurisdizioni quelle in blu che hanno
adottato dei carbon market dei mercati
analoghi e molte altre inter de nel
grafico che stanno costruendo o
ipotizzando di adottare e carbon markets
il progetto che io dirigo europeo
chiamato live set
vede la partecipazione dei governi dei
principali paesi principali carbon
marchi dalla commissione europea per
l'europa la svizzera dalla california al
quebec dalla cina alla nuova zelanda nel
tentativo di allineare questi diversi
mercati di scambiarci informazioni
chissà magari un giorno di arrivare a un
unico prezzo sarebbe bello perché avere
un unico prezzo sarebbe sì che non c'è
più incentivo a delocalizzare le
produzioni inquinanti e tanto paghi lo
stesso ma questo è molto dell'ancora da
ad avvenire al momento
quello che io definisco un esperimento
di laboratorio
una sorta di esperimento di cooperazione
internazionale per una politica globale
ma questo è in una scala diciamo quello
che viene fatto alla conferenza delle
nazioni unite quella che ogni anno si
tiene tra i paesi che hanno firmato la
convenzione quadro contro il cambiamento
climatico e sapete che l'ultima recente
si è tenuta a glasgow la cosiddetta top
twenty six 26 è il numero progressivo
del dell'incontro com'è andata
luci e ombre
i primi giorni c'è stato un grandissimo
entusiasmo anche perché continuavano ad
arrivare i grandi della terra che dal g7
di roma con un breve viaggio si sono
recati a glasgow
e in effetti abbiamo raggiunto dei
risultati forse insperati
fermare accordi volti a fermare la
deforestazione entro il 2030 firmato da
131 paesi eliminare i sussidi al carbone
entro prossimo anno e ridurre le
emissioni di metano che il secondo per
importanza fra i gas serra dopo la cina
2 ridurre del 30 per cento entro il 2030
firmato da 110 paesi
chi frequenta o chi segue le coop le
conference of the parties sa però che
tutto si decide alla fine quando si
spengono le luci della ribalta e grandi
della terra se ne vanno rimangono gli
sherpa
delegazioni che cercano accordi
bilaterali o multilaterali per l'accordo
finale ed è negli ultimi minuti che di
solito si decide cosa c'è esattamente in
quel testo qualche volta non bastano i
tempi regolamentari come questa volta è
successo si è andati a supplementari e
anche ai rigori
ai rigori
a rigori si sa a volte va bene
ea volte no
questa volta direi
abbiamo tirato alto sopra la traversa
nel senso che negli ultimi minuti della
conferenza sono arrivati i problemi
apparentemente
mascherati da una questione puramente
semantica cioè stato deciso sotto la
pressione di alcuni paesi di
cambiare un verbo da phase out a face
dow ora phase out significa eliminare
gradualmente
face dow significa ridurre gradualmente
una grande differenza perché se io
riduco gradualmente non voglio
necessariamente eliminarlo non mi do un
orizzonte temporale preciso e che cosa
ridurre gradualmente ridurre
gradualmente il carbone l'utilizzo del
carbone ei sussidi ai combustibili
fossili
e stato firmato da oltre 200 paesi e io
ho pensato vedi i membri fraseologico
andavano studiati meglio perché cambia
tutto il senso della frase ora a guidare
questo cambiamento
grammaticale sono alcuni paesi come
l'india o anche altri paesi in via di
sviluppo che non si sentono pronti alla
trasformazione dato che dipendono
fortemente ancora dal carbone però non
possiamo proprio dire che sono loro
brutti e cattivi è perché per la verità
noi paesi industrializzati siamo
arrivati a blasco senza aver fatto i
compiti ci eravamo impegnati con il
moduli the shore gol a fornire 100
miliardi di dollari all'anno ai paesi in
via di sviluppo nel periodo 2000 20 2026
ed è un impegno che ci eravamo presi già
dalla cop 15 che l'avete siamo troppo 26
è passato un bel po di tempo più di un
decennio
un impegno che non abbiamo mantenuto
perché siamo arrivati al 70 9.6 miliardi
di dollari e laici di stima che non
saremo in grado di mantenerlo prima del
2023 nelle ipotesi più ottimistiche e
questo è un bel problema è un bel
problema perché
i paesi in via di sviluppo hanno bisogno
del nostro supporto per adottare le loro
politiche allo stato attuale sono troppo
poveri per affrontare gli enormi costi
della decarbonizzazione dei costi delle
politiche di mitigazione e di
adattamento al cambiamento climatico in
corso ed è un enorme problema perché i
paesi in via di sviluppo hanno
contribuito meno degli altri ma
subiscono più degli altri
i danni dal cambiamento climatico e
voglia far vedere due mappe questa vi
mostra di chi è la colpa
ovvero chi ha contribuito maggiormente
alla alle emissioni attualmente in
atmosfera allo stock di co2 di gas serra
in atmosfera più il paese e scuro
maggiore è il contributo più è chiaro
minore e il contributo vedete stati
uniti cina russia europa giappone
emergono come grandi più contributori
e poi c'è tutta la sera dei paesi
bianchi il cui contributo è fra lo 0 e
lo 0,5 per cento
africa
buona parte dell'america latina buona
parte dell'asia ora guardate quest'altra
mappa mettetela confronto con la
prossima
questa vi dice chi subisce le
conseguenze dei cambiamenti climatici
più rosso e il paese maggiore è la
recessione cioè la riduzione prodotto
interno lordo che subisce e che è molto
rosso gli stessi l'africa l'america
latina buona parte dell'asia vedete
l'india
noi siamo di fronte a un problema
globale infatti si parla di global
warming è un problema globale non lo
risolviamo se non con una politica
globale quindi abbiamo bisogno di avere
dalla nostra parte questi paesi ma non
riusciremo a farlo se non manteniamo le
promesse
o parla di dare i numeri che vi ho dato
tanti numeri fatemi concludere con un
numero su tutti così e portate a casa il
ricordo di un numero solo se ho scelto
il 9 non è l'autobus
è la percentuale delle emissioni europee
sulle emissioni globali e la verità un
pochino meno dopo la break sit però se
consideriamo l'europa 28 cioè tenendo
ancora dentro gli inglesi anche se non
vogliono saremmo al 9 per cento
9 e anche il numero di anni che ci
separa alla fine del decennio
quindi il numero di anni che abbiamo per
realizzare questa politica fitball sul
ti fai
e questo è il punto sarà la capacità di
realizzare questa politica questo
obiettivo come passaggio intermedio
verso obiettivi ambiziosi sessualità
climatica sarà la nostra prova del nove
per vedere se facciamo sul serio e se le
nostre politiche sono credibili grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]